wasn't long ago in Gorman was winning
championships with a big fellow named
brevin Jordan John treats now joins us
in the newsroom with more on the former
tight end at Gorman who's now raising
cane on the football field in Miami hey
John that's right Chris there are very
few kids who when you look at them when
they're 16 and say he will play in the
NFL at Gorman breven Jordan was that guy
and he's only getting better at Miami
and more ready to rep los vegas in the
league as a 6-foot 3 240 pound tight end
brevin jordan is extraordinary he had
over 1,000 receiving yards in a season
in high school take a look at the video
here the Under Armour all-american took
his talents to Miami and earned
second-team all-acc as a freshman and in
first team all-conference as a sophomore
he is staring at being the top traffic
tight end at next year's draft and well
he's always reps Las Vegas you can hear
some of the Miami mighty guys appear you
in them how much does Brandon
representing Las Vegas and Bishop Gorman
I represent performing every day
especially me my guy bubbler and saying
all three of us we were saying Norman
die hard like we're like man nobody
could mess with us the Canes have three
football players from Las Vegas Chris